The US Air
Force just released
new video
showing what
the Air Force calls
an unnecessarily aggressive maneuver
by a Chinese military pilot
right in front of a U.S. aircraft.
CNN's Oren
Lieberman is live for us at the Pentagon.
And tell us what happened.
Jake, we're just getting this information
from U.S. Indo-Pacific command.
They say a Chinese fighter
jet at J-16 on Friday intercepted a U.S.
spy spy plane in international airspace
over the South China Sea.
They're calling it
an unnecessarily aggressive maneuver
as part of the intercept.
Take a look here.
This is from the cockpit of the U.S.
aircraft and RC one.
35, that Chinese fighter
jet off to the right
there as it cuts in front,
essentially slices
right in front of the U.S.
aircraft at fairly close range.
And that turbulence
there, that is from wake turbulence
off the back of that Chinese fighter jet.
Again, the U.S.
is calling this
an aggressive maneuver
saying that it was essentially unsafe
and unprofessional.
We have seen intercepts
like this,
this sort of tension
between Chinese fighter jets and U.S.
aircraft before, in fact,
there was one in December,
a different type of Chinese fighter jet,
but essentially the same situation.
The U.S.
said that their fighter jet
came within 20 feet in that instance
of the same U.S.
aircraft that RC one 35 river joint.
The US position is clear here.
They insist
they will continue to operate
in a safe and professional maneuver
anywhere, essentially
that international law allows.
And therein lies the dispute for the U.S.
airspace over much of the South China
Sea is international airspace
over international waters.
China, however, claims
much of the South China Sea
as its own territorial waters
and therefore believes
that it is the U.S.
invading on their territorial position.
The U.S.
does not recognize
it is at this point
one in a number of elements
or aspects, adding tension
to the relationship
between Beijing and Washington
at this point.
And we're seeing that play out
in a different environment as well, Jake.
Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin
in the Indo-Pacific
for the Shangri-La Dialog.
He was trying to set up a meeting
with his Chinese counterpart.
China rejecting that dialog, Jake.
So you see that
tension playing out across
different aspects of the relationship.
What do you see when you look at this?
How dangerous is it?
Obviously, a very unprofessional
and dangerous act
by what appears to be
the j-16 fighter pilot.
As soon as I saw this tape,
I was reminded the event back in 2001.
We saw a Chinese J eight fighter aircraft
collide with the Navy P-3 aircraft
over the South China Sea.
So in the same area,
the result was
the Chinese aircraft was destroyed,
the pilot was killed.
And we almost lost an entire aircraft
full of of American servicemen and women.
Fortunately, they landed on Hainan Island
in Chinese territory.
Now, imagine that was 20 years ago.
Imagine that same event happening today
with the tensions
that we have between our two nations.
Very dangerous.
And the Chinese need to condemn it.